you have another one that what's
depressing yeah give me another one
hello Bobo koloko Gilbert and the white
man hello
I am a huge fan of your podcast and love
your unhelpful advice portion I am a
sophomore in college and I've won a
tattoos all my life since I was a child
when my super conservative Korean
parents would practically disowned me if
I got any they say I would be
disrespecting them as parents by god
anything
I thought about getting some and hiding
them with cover-up or long sleeves
whenever I visit home but I dream of
having lots of tattoos what should I do
is it worth potentially disappointing my
parents have what I've always wanted my
whole life or should I just give up
jelly I think that Asian parents give a
lot of empty threats because I think I
felt like my mom was very similar mm-hmm
I wouldn't do it you would not do it I
would get here says the guy with the
tattoo that I'm looking at literally
right now yeah because I regret all your
tattoos I have you do I do
oh I think that but what are their cool
tattoos yeah like what is this I don't
know actually
it actually does kind of look like a
weird stamp from a nightclub that you
forgot about little bit and you can see
like little like because they have to
cover it up all the time oh yeah
first question ever gonna be in movies
Roy yeah I used even if I wasn't in the
business I just regret them but that's
just me right but she loves hers some
right there's something yeah I got a
random tattoo I hate it and I tried
covering it up for it didn't quite work
yeah yeah so I mean and I work at a
tattoo shop for several years yeah and I
always just tell people it's like you
really have to sit down and think about
it because the way you want to express
yourself today is not necessarily how
you want to express yourself later and
that's just on you forever and you're
you know removing tattoos is three times
more painful yeah okay could I make a
quick pitch if we're talking bad advice
here yeah here's what you do get a [ __ ]
ton of the great really good temporary
tattoos but you can do it any Halloween
store
what you do is then go to the go to the
house with the parents see if it gives
them a heart attacks and kills them
they're dead yeah you win you go get the
tattoos done permanently yeah if they
survive they stay
just disowned you and you're like joke
alcohol rub them off now I know how you
really feel I didn't die which you said
you would but what I'm hoping end up
happening and yes I really I like this
idea yes you wear them it's like gasps
ooh gasps like them right Koreans are
fighting kids are violent yes so they'll
hit you in the face oh my god right well
then then when you get hit in the face
you know hopefully it's that it's brutal
enough where meat leaves a mark then you
go get real ones
everybody's weeping right dude that
thing right out of the way and then you
go get them [ __ ] stamps together let's
say a rising tide rods all holes
oh that's so that's so just be clear
about what you want don't I said do it
yeah [ __ ] it but I don't I don't know
Asian parents oh I don't know
[Music]